[Music]
please don't get involved
it is monday morning
live from calabasas not live but
it's live for me right now you know so
that's cool uh big week for your boy man
big week for your boy my special
the gringo poppy drops this thursday
morning thursday morning on thick boy
youtube it is 30 minutes of pure fury
lighten up my latin family kids girl
grandma everybody gets it so hopefully
you guys enjoy it here is a sneak peek
at my
30 minute special that drops this
freaking thursday on youtube it is the
gringo poppy enjoy i married a mexican
y'all i'm the only person in my house
who don't speak spanish my white friends
aren't a latina before i go dude just
[ __ ] learn spanish put a little
effort in and learn spanish how hard can
it be my [ __ ] i am 38
i struggle with english at times
like my women like my check so make sure
that it's dead keep it real and make
them stand up like comedienne
boys goes dude dude deal with a latina
bro you know why because they're fun and
they're spicy you know what spicy means
they're [ __ ] that's what that means
i decided to go on a keto diet you know
what keto is keto is a diet where you
can't eat mexican food that's the diet
mama what are you doing i know you know
i'm on keto lebron look mojitos it's
keto [ __ ]
are we gonna eat bean cheese bean cheese
bean cheese mint cheese i'm just gonna
carb load year round we're all gonna be
built like armadillos the other thing
you should know about dana mexican
nobody told me this there's many flaming
hot cheetos all over your house
there it is man your boy worked hard
self-funded
self
created if you want to say i use my team
the thick boy team we shot in dallas
texas at the addison improv i set my set
designer down there brian johnson to
recreate the the backdrop so it looked
like a special we filmed five freaking
shows which if you know how specials
work if you're with netflix or comic
central usually at that very most you
get two but since i was doing it um
you know we were able to shoot a lot
more shows just to make sure you have
exactly what you want um and you know i
i guess for me
you know as a comic there's not a lot of
material out there in the universe i
have the economy central that's not
happening uh which is on youtube uh but
you know i was damned i filmed that six
years ago you know so other than that
you know my showtime special is not out
there that's behind the showtime
subscription paywall um
so
i just wanted
the most eyeballs the the most
availability uh for my fans and also new
fans that see how hard i've worked at
this uh
you know this lane that that we call
stand-up man and i've put everything uh
that i can into it and uh
the the original idea was to shoot it
exactly the way i want edit cut it
exactly 30 minutes
and sell it to one of these major
networks where you guys are all familiar
with
and which i did and i i met with them
and it's been this whole process
and then um
i don't know probably about
four or five weeks ago
i got the okays
from some of these major outlets to uh
by the special
and uh i when i met with him i said okay
would you what are you guys gonna do
promo wise and how am i gonna grow as a
stand-up comic and they told me and
these billboards and commercial stuff
and in my head like i can do all that i
have the team and i think boy stews i
have the staff who guys who have shot
specials before we own all the equipment
i can do all this
and so
i just think at the end of the day um
i've i've never been wrong i've always
banked on myself and and my fan base and
the the best
thing for me at this time in 202 was to
make it available to everybody
and um this is nothing new guys have
done this like mark norman and shane
gillis which have blown up
on uh their specials so
um i'm banking on myself man i'm banking
on my fan base making this thing a
success whatever that means i i don't
know i honestly i don't know
what that looks like i haven't given it
much thought but um
you know i i know whenever i bank on
myself and when my gut tells me this is
the direction you should go i'm usually
right man and so uh
i'm hoping other comics will will see
this and again i i'm not writing uh
creating
the the wheel here other comics have
done it like shane gillis and mark
norman
but um i'm hoping that some of my fans
whether you're a comic or not see this
and realize that
you know you don't need the big machine
and you know these other networks which
i'm not going to mention because i've i
do have great relationships with him and
maybe in the future um i would want my
next special with him i don't know but i
know where i'm at right now
currently
um on april 25th on monday morning
what's best for me
is to make sure everybody possible can
see
how much i've grown as a stand-up comic
how much work i've put in and this is
the best i got man it's the best i got i
think you guys will enjoy it that clip
was just a little sneak peek and uh
hopefully i made you guys proud for the
fans out there uh hopefully it's
something you can stand by and retweet
and re-share and uh send clips to your
friends and family and um that's that's
my hope man so hopefully i made you guys
proud man and it's it's the gringo
poppings the the the best i can do man
so um
you know i go back on the road you see
me uh on this pr tour that i'm doing
which again you know with the showtime
special and whenever i you know i've had
big things come up you know these these
people that i'm that i used to be with
would would hire a publicist and put me
on all these
shows you know and stuff like that and i
said man if you're going to do this
yourself go all the way don't just do it
all yourself and then hire the pr team
and you know the publicist and the
marketing strategy make sure it's all
yourself
and it's been exhausting that's probably
why i look so tired on here every week
because my team's in workless
been working endless hours to to get
this done and create the clips and the
marketing and line up um you know this
this pr tour that kicks off really it
kicked off last week uh but you guys
won't see it until this week you'll see
uh i'll be on uh bert kreicher's show
this week logan paul
uh i'm on rogan on thursday and i come
back to uh l.a spend time with my family
and i leave sunday for new york in new
york you'll see me on flagrant 2 christa
stefano show garyvee bar stool
and some other shows and i go straight
from new york to charlotte
where i'm back on tour it's a
whole new hour anything you saw on the
the gringo poppy special you will not
see um on my future tour dates i know
some comics will kind of play with it
and have some bits from their special in
there i don't do that um i think what
keeps people coming out to the shows is
is new new content new material so uh
you'll see a whole new hour and uh i've
been working hard at this new hour and
charlotte i will see you guys uh was
that may 5th through the 7th of comedy
zone and tickets at thickboy.com right
now
and uh
going into the special um you know i
love my fashion i love my merch so we
have the shirt i'm wearing right now the
the gringo poppy thick boy
shirt which uh drops tuesday morning at
9 00 a.m
so show your support go get the
specialty
they made a limited edition limited
amount of these it is designed by your
boy you're looking at his thick ass
so uh
yeah it's personal man i uh i put a lot
of effort into this so
show your support we're doing uh sign
giveaways five people
get uh the i think it's a five by seven
uh cut out that we printed out of the
special um promo the picture uh that we
did for it leading up to it
so five people will get that sign plus a
bottle of tiger thick and they're gonna
do this giveaway based on using the
hashtag the gringo poppy and show us on
thursday the most creative way you're
watching the special and the five
most creative
best pictures on instagram using the
hashtag my team's gonna go through and
our five favorites which the entire
staff is gonna pick here the five
favorites that gets voted our favorite
you're gonna receive that signed 5x7
poster and the tiger thick whiskey as
well and then uh the rest of
the people that participate i think
we're doing over 200 i'm signing today
over 200 5x7 posters of the gringo poppy
uh cover art
you'll get those in the mail so that's
what we're doing man the hashtag is the
gringo poppy blast it out share with
your friends hopefully you guys dig it
and uh charlotte i will see you may 5th
through the 7th and then philadelphia
europe may 19th through the 21st and
then uh
in june i'm in portland june 9th through
the 11th but charlotte you're up next
and uh
i'm excited man i'm excited i work my
ass off and i know you guys uh know that
and you'll see it in this special the
green girl poppy drops thursday morning
and your boy
is going on a pr tour that i've set up
completely myself so let's see how it
goes man but i think this is the route
for your boy we'll see
and again i don't know what success
means when it comes to this stuff i
really don't i don't
so uh you just put it out you hope for
the best you hope people watch hopefully
you guys love it and you dig it and come
out to the shows and show your support
so
that's how we'll be able to see if this
thing's a success or not but i love you
guys for all the support buying the
merch buying the tickets give me a
career a knucklehead like me a career in
stand-up comedy and i can't thank you
guys enough so that's
a special shout out to all the fans this
this one is for you guys believe that
nobody else if other people watch it
great but if just my crew watches it all
good baby that's why we do it you guys
have rode with me this long so hopefully
i made you proud the gringo poppy
special drops this thursday
um outside that man lots going on in the
fight world we got a special show today
we got one of my very very favorite
people
in all of combat sports
i think he's the smartest guy doing it
he's my go-to whenever i have a question
or if i need more insight to a fight
that maybe you know went to split
decision i usually tend to agree with
him 99.9 of the time
he's uh a lot smarter than me we know
this and uh
he's we used to be uh
teammates you could say at show time uh
i still have a lot of friends at
showtime and shout out to showtime and
he's the face of showtime now so please
enjoy
the one the only luke thomas let's take
a little break from hear me yap about
the fight game cause man
y'all need some sleep these days your
boy i know i look tired i know i got
bags in my eyes i know i look like a
thick panda right now that's all good
dude that's why the new tour is called
trash panda i look like a panda you guys
thinking raccoon cause they call them
trash pandas no i'm talking about an
actual panda in a trash can i'm thick
i'm like a panda
so listen i need sleep
but i found sleep that's right i sleep
hard because i have the best mattress in
the world i should just buy your generic
mattresses and think it's all good it's
not all good we're grown-ups now i'm a
father of two how about that i'm a
married man i'm a father of two i can't
sleep on your generic mattress with a
bad back i got a helix sleep mattress
son that's right it's made just for my
thick ass i took a quiz it took two
minutes and then what you know what we
got the perfect mattress for your thick
body they match the mattress to your
body that's right you not generic not
for everybody not very joe schmoe out
there we're talking just you it's
uniquely made just for you what do you
like soft firm sleep on your side your
back your stomach you sleep hot cold
whatever it is
helix sleep is there for you because
they make it just for you don't take my
word for it helix sleep was awarded the
number one best overall mattress of 2019
and 2020 by gq and wired magazine ever
heard of them i have
helix sleep was even awarded the number
one best overall matches by the same
outlet in 2019 and 2020 by gq and wired
magazine i'm at my house i can't get rid
of my in-laws can't get rid of my
parents my brother my brother's friends
my kids friends my kids parents
everyone's like i thought they liked me
i'm all right i'm not that cool where i
can't get rid of them it's the mattress
so unless you're ready to have people
trying to sleep over all the time as
grown men adults men women children then
you ain't ready for helix because the
best mattress you're ever gonna have
just go to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they will match you with the perfect
mattress just for you so you get the
best sleep of your life they have a 10
year warranty you get to try out 100
nights risk free all right and listen if
you don't like it leave them pick it up
for you but i promise you you're gonna
love it so don't worry about that
also you're like dude i'm in
all right say less check this out
because i'm gonna say more helix leap is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and free pillows for the
listeners and viewers of the shop show
helix sleep.com shop for 200 dollars off
and free pillows that's helixsleep.com
for up to 200 off now let's get back to
the show uh let's get into some fight
talk man there's a lot to dive into
you're one of my favorite people to
discuss all this with
are you obviously you're seeing the the
rumblings of jon jones stipe on this big
summer card
i you know i don't work for the ufc i
you know i have no association with the
ufc obviously cover the ufc that's my
bread and butter because i fought in the
ufc but
i would almost guarantee from what i
hear my sources i'd almost guarantee
that's the fight of the summer jon jones
stipe
i don't okay so in theory and in
actuality
in all ways i do really like this fight
but for me and i guess this is the
intrigue but it's also intriguing also
like a little bit of trepidation
i just
don't know what to expect from john i
mean there's questions about steve bay 2
how does he recover from the bad loss to
francis he's had some time off where is
he in all of this and father time by the
way i think he's kicking 40's door down
at this point or pretty close to it so
there's plenty of questions on stipe's
side but dude the questions on john's
side are absolutely enormous the last
time we saw him i thought he lost that
fight to dominic reyes i know it was
close it's the only time i've ever
scored a fight not for john that went to
a decision i know some folks did for the
gustafson fight i did not i did not i
thought he beat dustinson but you know
either way i'm just sort of pointing out
i thought dominic gray has beat him
cleanly and then uh you know he has all
the time off and folks always forget
this too he didn't just have the issue
in las vegas where he headbutted the car
and whatever else happened in that hotel
room with his um
with the mother of his children
yeah but then prior to that during when
when when pandemic was at its like peak
and there were still quarantines and
[ __ ] remember he was arrested in
downtown albuquerque when albuquerque
was abandoned basically
firing off allegedly guns into the air
and then he had the bottle of rico
in his car and they didn't make him
really sit through any of the legal
process because there was concern about
jails being overcrowded and and kova
spreading through the prison population
or whatever so they just let him ride
it's like dude i'm not saying that those
i'm not here to like weigh in on the
legality of it or what it all should
have happened i'm just saying
[ __ ] man time off plus a new weight
class plus those two other things in
there plus was his performance declining
at the end of light heavyweight i think
that it was
what kind of jon jones are we going to
get boy good [ __ ] question because i
don't have an answer for you i have no
[ __ ] clue what he's going to look
like
but does see to me that's what makes
this so exciting
because with steep a there's a lot of
questions to be answered with john who i
think is the greatest we've ever seen
inside the octagon going to heavyweight
and you know him having this time off
then obviously all the legal troubles
and you know he's put on weight uh stipe
has put on weight i don't know if you've
heard dc talk about it but um i talked
to chael about this too apparently
stipes put on like 15 pounds of lean
muscle
he's a lot bigger a lot stronger
he's never looked better is what i'm
hearing from my sources so
when i hear these things and obviously i
you know when you mention you know
john his last fight with don mcgregor's
and you know i'll give john a little bit
of leniency there i don't think it's
father time and he's he's getting worse
i literally don't think he's giving up
for those light heavyweight fights if
you look at his career and the magnitude
of fight that he's been in
these young lions that don't have these
huge names i think he's he's coasting it
and there is you know some you know
weight too that he might have lost that
don mcgregor's fight man you you go back
and score that thing it's like that that
was not a good looking jon jones so
maybe i'm just biased i you know i i do
think john kind of coasts his way
through that
somehow still got it done which is
insane but to me the this
the question of unknown is what makes
this one of the greatest heavyweight
fights of all time and then john let's
say john beats stipe which depending who
you talk to especially in your business
the media some have stipa is the
greatest heavyweight in the ufc of all
time
you know if jon beats him
my god
then then i i really think it forces
dana's hand which is the next thing that
we're gonna get to this is a great segue
it leads to francis singano and then so
if john gets by stipe who some regards
grace heavyweight all the time and
obviously francis beat him but
now you got francis waiting in the
[ __ ] helms
who's a free agent basically
and tyson free just had an amazing
knockout and then
brings francis into the ring and they do
this promo
so there's that so i think this actually
the winner of all this is francis
because if jon were to win against stipe
we're gonna want to see john
francis but then francis has this
guaranteed huge payday with with uh
tyson fury so i think it's going to
force the ufc's hand to make that deal
with
francis and play ball which i pray to
god that they come to terms with francis
because if it's a francis tyson fury
fight
we need dana and the ufc involved man
there's boxing promoting sucks i need to
work for showtime i don't anymore so i
can say this stuff the the boxing
pronoun is [ __ ] terrible dude it's
awful there's nobody better in the in
sports when it comes to marketing hype
in a fight than the ufc and that
marketing machine that they put behind
these fighters so if they get involved
like they did with connor and floyd my
god dude my word is it exciting yeah
okay a few things there the one thing
let me go back to the john stephen thing
then i'll follow up with the the francis
side
the one reason why
i feel s again i'm not majorly different
a little different than you is because
for example if we got an announcement
today that we were going to get spence
versus crawford you could argue that you
know 32 33 versus 34 whatever it is
would be a little bit later than we
wanted it but you could still say that
both guys are either at their prime or
pretty close to we'd have a very clear
sense of their abilities there would
still be mystery about the outcome but
you knew you were getting premium
product in either direction the issue i
have with stipe versus john is not that
they're not premium quality talents they
have proven to be some of the very best
we have ever seen but those questions
make me wonder if what happens if we end
up getting an underwhelming fight and an
underwhelming performance in one
direction or the other those questions
would then lead us to uh have been
uh have been well served because we were
sort of pointing out that
vulnerabilities had been
um not just exposed but have been that's
a it's a big part of who they are at
this point they cannot get over some of
those things so that's one thing i'd say
is a little bit different
getting to francis
see here's the thing
this is a complicated question because i
was talking about this my co-host brian
campbell he was saying something similar
to you which was what if the ufc gets
involved in a potential fury fight
i could agree i could agree that the ufc
getting involved would send the level of
promotion into overdrive over what it
would be
however even without them i would argue
that it would still sell a lot and if
you're francis you don't have to give 50
or whatever the cut would be to ufc so
like what would be the incentive for
francis to want to work with ufc for the
boxing fight unless they give him a
contract that is just
next level which i don't think i don't
know if they're gonna wanna do man i
guess we're gonna have to see
yeah again i i think it goes back and i
you know i i love when
fighters have
some sort of leverage over the man the
ufc not that because i'm anti-dane or
anti-the establishment i just love when
these fighters through blood sweat and
tears have some sort of advantage and i
think nobody has more of an advantage
than francis because
again i'm
i'm going all over the place and i'm
sure we'll get to it but you know it's
it's the same thing with uh like jake
paul
it's like jake paul connor jake paul
nate diaz the oven is on dude this thing
is preheating those fights are gonna
happen with or without dana in the ufc
so if i'm the ufc
i want some of that pie that's about to
get [ __ ] baked man now if you don't
do it and you don't play the the game
you're gonna miss out on it but if
you're just cool and you somehow come to
agreement with these huge names the
biggest names in your promotion
you're gonna get a share of this so it's
either
you get some of the pie you're not gonna
get all of it like you're used to but
you're gonna get some of it and be
associated with it which is great for
the brand or you get nothing either way
that oven is preheating the it's that
oven is on for francis tyson fury the
oven's on for jake paul and conor
mcgregor that oven's on for jake paul
and nate diaz those are happening
whether it's now or in two three years
so if i'm the ufc
i think for the first time
because of jake paul and because of
francis they've taken these risks and
it's paid off that they have this
leverage and if i'm the ufc i'm just i'm
sitting there in the morning monday
meeting going
guys i know we use we don't typically do
this
but that that that pie is going to get
baked man let's get in on this pie i i
know usually we take 50 percent these
guys ain't going for 50 percent but
let's be involved in some capacity
whatever that means
yeah so maybe there's a better way to
come to it because you know with
mcgregor they took 50 or close to it
maybe there's a way where they don't
take quite 50 but they take a portion 25
30 something like that yep and yeah and
then offer all of their resources behind
promotion to blow it up as big as
possible then of course he would give
pay-per-view points and then get more
money potentially back in that's what he
wins
yes that seems that seems more feasible
to me but the other part you have to
really consider here is francis is what
35 i think almost 36 coming off a a knee
surgery and a potential layoff
if you're the ufc you also have to
figure out what kind of contract you
might want to offer him because 35 is
not old for heavyweight but no here's
something to think about what if you
give this guy all the money in the world
you only take 25 off a potential fight
with tyson fury you promote the [ __ ] out
of him and then fury goes in there and
bulldozes him now you might have a guy
who loses which again most people might
expect him to lose if it's a pure boxing
match but just sort of pointing out
let's say francis is made to look bad
something like that
and then uh now you've got an older guy
you can't really
use like you thought you could
because now he's somewhat damaged goods
and he also father time has caught up
with him like you're catching him at
this moment where he's peaking ready to
make the biggest fights with the biggest
money but he may in theory it's possible
not be that far from the downside given
the time off given the surgery and
everything else potential motivation
issues too if he gets a whole lot of
money that could prevent you from then
cashing in on whatever celebrity he
could have put together by virtue of
fighting fury like if you're the ufc you
got to play this one real carefully
about whether you go all in or not on
this thing because you could die you
could you could [ __ ] it up yeah that's a
great point it's a great point i i still
think regardless even if he were to get
absolutely
mollywhopped against tyson fury
they're still them being involved the
money they'd make from that i think they
can come to some sort of agreement on
his ufc contract where they don't
completely lose their ass you know and
you and you not only did you get the rub
no matter what happens tyson fury fight
for francis you get the rub of all those
eyeballs there's not a bigger person in
boxing tyson fury not even close so you
get all the rub of those eyeballs and
then you go hey and then
what's next for francis that we just put
all this marketing to well now he's
fighting jon jones so as a as a fan as a
former fighter it's like francis is
going to get life-changing money from
tyson and uh
that fight and then he's also
gonna just parlay that into one the
biggest if not the biggest fight of all
time against jon jones
it it it to me it's a no-brainer like
the ufc is gonna get theirs even if
francis gets mollywoped
yes there are a lot of scenarios where
they win i just mean if you're francis
you got a lot of careful choices you got
to make too about
what's the best for your brand what
happens because there's going to be life
after the fury fight too in all
likelihood right so what does life look
like after the fury fight you have to
manage where you could go because here's
the thing everyone's like oh he can make
a ton of money with the fury fight
unless he shows some kind of
extraordinary performance in there
what's after that
it's not so clear to me i guess you
could fight other big name boxers if he
looks good enough or something but
you're saying if you're you'll hunt luke
you're saying if he didn't uh resign
with ufc like he just fights
yeah okay yeah so yeah
yeah what does a post fury life look
like i mean there's a lot of it's a lot
of ways he has to be
very careful it's all good options but
they're all different options and they
mean different things for the next stage
in his career it's not just about the
one fight it's about what's the next
three to four years look like if that's
really where he wants to be it's it's
it's it's a difficult situation for him
although a good one in many ways
obviously a great one and
as a fan and for what we do
it's going to be even i think more
exciting if going into that fury fight
we know there's a deal with the ufc so
we know no matter what happens a fury
fight we're gonna get the jon jones
thing you know so i i i just feel like
especially for what we do
there's just so much to to bite into
it's such a perfect set up man
also i'll say this it's amazing i'll add
this too i mean i do think that it
probably is worth pointing out canelo
alvarez is probably the biggest star in
boxing but canelo has less than zero
interest in fighting kumar uzman so it's
you know who cares
but with fury who's a massive massive
star as you saw over the weekend and of
course in the uk in particular he has a
total willingness it seems to do
outrageous [ __ ] and the thing that i
don't think is all that out of bounds i
don't know what they're going to do but
to me the big knock on mayweather
mcgregor was it was just a straight-up
boxing match and that was just you know
it was going to be hard for mcgregor
under any circle the heart is going to
be hard yes right especially like you're
going against [ __ ] floyd like it's
going to be hard but dude here's one
thing
they could you we've we've both seen one
championship where they do the muay thai
with the four ounce gloves in the cage i
don't know if it has to be in the cage
but dude if tyson fury and you got to
give him all the credit in the world if
he does this if he agrees to four ounce
gloves and maybe a little bit of dirty
boxing in the rule set are you [ __ ]
me that to me is a is i won't say a
crazy different fight but that's a
different fight than if it's just
straight up boxing that way
i would i would i would be overjoyed
quite frankly to see something along
those lines with four ounce clubs
it makes it more intriguing for guys
like us my my
issue with that
and i mean chael talked about this my
issue with that is
if you do these weird rules you the
casuals are they don't keep up like we
they're not balls deep in the game like
we are so you're gonna miss out the
casual like hold on wait wait so the the
the best boxer right now is fighting the
ufc heavyweight champ and what are they
doing so i if you go to if it gets too
confusing or you do these something that
hasn't been done before it's these weird
rules i think
that it it makes it kind of difficult
for people to really buy into that's
what i get where
for you and me it's like what four ounce
gloves tyson's gonna do that this is
[ __ ] great but it's like i think for
the the casual fan it gets a little
dicey and all we want is france to make
the most money possible yeah i do think
that is doing traditional boxing could
be again racing goes i'm retiring
because i'm retiring i'm doing
entertainment fight so i'm down for four
ounce gloves now if you want to me
the best idea that i've heard
it's it's in a boxing ring like tyson is
well known for
and the only change is everything's same
round same corner same everything the
same but they're in four ounce gloves
i'm in
yes yeah if you wanted to keep it where
it all looked kind of the same except
for those things you have gloves even
that to me and again you're right i can
only speak for my consumer preferences
as a consumer because you know
francis versus tyson in a boxing fight
you know ty uh francis's chances are
just not great and even with four
hundred clubs i would say his chances
aren't great but i would say
it gets equalized a little bit by virtue
of francis's outrageous [ __ ]
power with the four ounce gloves dude
again there they would have to be some
market research for the promoters to
figure out what's what either way you
know france is making the most of what
we want but i gotta tell you personally
speaking personally i'd be significantly
more intrigued if they weren't at least
at a bare minimum just just if nothing
else the four ounce gloves as opposed to
8 10 or whatever
me too i'm i'm all in yeah take my take
my money i'm freaking in um
now are you uh obviously you're a purist
to some extent are you a fan of the
the the jake paul stuff and the logan
paul stuff like are you are you
all for it as far as you know jake paul
and you know he was just that two weeks
ago uh i was logan paul last week doing
his show promo for the special but
i was jake paul came to my show at the
improv and we were talking in the green
room and i said this on the show and i
said on logan paul's show but
um me and jake are you know just talking
i get off stage and he's back there and
we're shooting the [ __ ] and he goes hey
man you think i have a chance to get in
that conor mcgregor fight
and i said i do i i actually do i you
know the ufc the you know especially
dana he's a businessman and
he never said no the door is open
i said but the the caveat there
is your terms
you mentioned that if you beat connor
dana has to change forever
fighter pay
i said and and i i get why you're doing
that and that's obviously the knock and
dana i get all that but you have to
realize i said let's let's
exaggerate here let's say dana which
they're not let's say dana makes a
hundred million dollars off of you and
connor dana alone makes 100 million
dollars the ufc does
that he's still going to lose money if
he changes the fighters minimum page
forever if you think about over the
course of 10 years you're talking
potentially billions of dollars how many
fights they put on a year billions of
dollars so it makes no sense
and so i thought jake was doing
the fighter pay thing as kind of you
know a marketing thing to get under
dana's skin because the number one thing
people come at dana for
and which even i've backed off of
because i don't know i don't i'm not
their accountant i have no idea what it
takes to run the oc i don't know i have
no clue but when it comes to jake i
thought he was just doing it as kind of
a mark and play to get fighters and
people on his side because you know he
gets so much hate
and when i told him that he goes then i
won't do it man
what do you mean he goes if you don't
change fight or pay i won't even
entertain it i'll just fight conor when
he's out of his contract and then take
care of the fighters on the other card
i'm one of the reasons i'm doing this
obviously you'd be huge in the ufc but
i'm doing it to change the game and make
sure these fighters get taken care of i
went oh [ __ ] you're serious about this
he goes yeah man i won't do it if you
don't agree to that
that's admirable i mean i've had a i
yeah i've had a halfway or a mo i would
say maybe 75 percent change of heart on
jake paul so i'll say the good part
first and the part where i haven't had a
change so the first part i would say is
remember you have amanda serrano katie
taylor this weekend which with the mvp
promotions which is his promotional
company along with eddie hearn is
putting on um at madison square garden i
mean that's big dude he has blown up
amanda serrano's profile more than
anyone else has including herself she
needed a little bit of help obviously
and jake came in and has done wonders
for her that's an important fight in the
history of women's boxing i give him all
the credit in the world for
what he has done to not really raise her
profile but um you know to give to to
not just be a complete taker in the
sport of boxing uh so i'll say that i
think that's pretty which is rare
which is rare and the second part is i
worked a couple of his shows when he was
doing them with tyron woodley and i i
found out like dude for folks who may
not realize this dude jake paul ran 50
of everything you saw everything you saw
he had a hand in from the weigh-ins to
how the fights looked the arena
everything the promotion how it looked
mean he wasn't hands on with the editing
for you know some of the showtime stuff
but you get the idea dude like him and
his company were majorly involved in
that he's got smart people around him
like i do have respect for his hustle
and the vision and then the execution
now
the part that i just can't come around
on is do i think he's a good boxer no do
i think he's ever going to be a good
boxer no
um he's not and i found that his fights
with tyron were except for the knockout
in the second one were largely pretty
boring
um that would be my criticism it just
didn't it just didn't entertain me but i
don't hate on his hustle i definitely
don't hate on what he's doing for boxing
and the last thing i'd say is when his
brother logan was fighting ksi on the
zone this was not the first one they had
but they had a subsequent one where he
was on his own
and
you know my argument at the time was
well okay i definitely agree that these
youtubers fighting brings attention to
the events that they're on and i don't
think it hurts boxing but i did not see
it as any kind of real way to recruit a
younger audience over time they have
done subsequent studies well i got to
tell you i thought that was true
but the subsequent studies have shown
dude no sport has added a bigger portion
of the youthful audience in the last 10
years than boxing it's had the most
growth really and yeah and people under
25 years old i don't know what else you
could trace that to other than this
youtube crossover phenomena now i still
am skeptical that someone watches jake
paul and then goes oh i want to see
errol spence versus ugas i
i i don't quite understand that
connection
but but the amount of young people
watching boxing relative to what it was
10 years ago is massively increased you
got to give him at least among some
other folks you got to give him credit
for that as well and i do i just don't
find his boxing very entertaining
you didn't find it entertaining when uh
when he fought ben askren or when he
fought no the basketball player when he
just starched him no dude if i want to
see random knockouts i could just go to
a gym or regional mma
that doesn't do [ __ ] for me i mean are
they nice knockouts yeah they're fine
but
was i entertained no i was not
entertained
agree it'd be tough to pay 80 bucks for
that if you know if that's what he was
going to do i you know he isn't a
you know i don't want to say tough
position because he definitely calls his
and it's obviously his promotion stuff
like that he has to be careful the route
that he's gonna go because he wants to
be taken serious so he has to fight
guys that the the fan base takes serious
and you know i i told him this in person
i said i i you know he called out
michael bisming
i said that's not the move man
to me that's not the move i said you
know you're calling out a guy who who's
not only he's retired but you know also
has one eye uh he has one eye you know
he has some injuries
and you know i know he doesn't get your
numbers as far as what you do on your
podcast or you know what your brother
does on his podcast and your instagram
following but you know he he's parlayed
his career into something pretty cool
man especially for guys like us like
he's biswing's killing it man he's in
his own lane he talks a lot of [ __ ] but
you know
he's if you're looking for that
validation
i don't think that's it
and i also think that i i know you see
this older guy and he has one eye
bisping's [ __ ] tough dude if he took
this serious and bismuth with some uh
you know
form of his his old self the pressure he
brings like biswing can [ __ ] fight
dude you're talking about a guy that's
no quit you know there's it's not it's
just not in him so you're biting off a
lot there and but you're also going for
a guy who's completely out of the game
um if i said if you want those same out
accolades and you also want the respect
of the the ufc fan base go for anderson
silva
he's he's he's active he just beat julio
chavez jr who's legit as it gets when it
comes to boxing now is he canelo no far
from it the guy's [ __ ] 50 professional
wins his dad's you know a [ __ ] god
when it comes to boxing like if you're
looking for those acolytes and you want
a tough tough opponent it's anderson
silva man that's your guy he's one of
the greatest if not the greatest to ever
do it and he's he's he's there he's
active
so to me that would be the direction he
should go if that's what he wants yeah
see i don't know if that's what he wants
i mean again you know him better than i
do but i asked him once like what like
what's when it's all said and done
what's the goal in boxing and his answer
was quick and it was unequivocal it was
i think it was either 150 million or 250
million but the point i'm trying to make
is he didn't say [ __ ] about anybody's
respect
he never said i want to be a world
champion at least not to me he didn't
tell me he wanted to like make sure that
the fans knew he was number one he was
coming into this game looking to make a
fortune in prize fighting
uh and then you know potentially get the
[ __ ] out and i gotta tell you he told
hbo real sports i don't know if it's
true although if it is true it would be
a function of what he made from his
purse as well as through the promotional
company but he told him he made 45
million from boxing last year i mean i
think what he wants at the end of the
day is to get paid
which he's uh he's succeeding i mean
here's the thing i mean everyone's like
oh you got to fight and silver for the
for the
for the
validation to prove to prove yeah the
validation that's right it's a better
way of putting validation and you're
right if he fought anderson silva and
beat him i mean at that point you really
would have to give him a level of
respect but i think anderson silva would
[ __ ] him up to be quite honest with you
um
very tough fight yeah i mean at a bare
minimum it would not be easy it would
not be easy and i would favor someone to
win
also the other part two is you know
listen man this dude has used mma to
boost his profile more than anyone maybe
ever it's
floyd was the first guy genius yeah
floyd was the first guy to piss off mma
fans to boost his profile then took the
mcgregor fight dude here comes jake paul
being like huh let me see if i can
follow that and he is needling everybody
along the way and getting [ __ ] loads of
attention for it and i don't think he
has really any intention of fighting all
the people that they want him to fight
yeah i you know he i i do think he you
know and
i've had conversations i do
think obviously money's the motivator
but
you know i'm not saying anything that he
wouldn't say
and
i think he'll act like you know i don't
care about validation that you know i'm
making all this money
he does care trust me he does care he
wants that acceptance he wants to be
taken serious even though he goes i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm knocked these guys
out i no i get it and you're making all
the money in the world i know deep down
he wants that validation and he he has
to be very careful with the opponents
that he selects because to you to your
point i do not think anderson silva is a
smart fight and and i know poking the
bear you know this this [ __ ] british
bear and michael bisping
be careful dude i know he has one eye
but you talk you know i i came up with
bisbee he's a [ __ ] monster dude if
you poke that [ __ ] british bear you
know so yeah um and there was tommy fury
who could have him too
i was just going to say there was tommy
fury over the weekend and this is the
first time i ever watched the fight i
mean who's to say like it's hard to know
how good either these guys are because
we just they keep fighting people who
don't really tell us what the answer is
but
uh i might favor jake paul over tommy
fury next to be quite honest with you if
they thought i think i i think i'm ready
to make that make that move yeah me too
all right
i made that move six months ago i think
jake starts tommy fury i think yeah i
think he knocks him out in the third or
fourth round uh you might be right
yeah yeah yeah but that again that
doesn't that's
he'll make some money but tommy fury's
not like this huge star thing about he's
on the undercard of his brothers you
know obviously it's his brother's
[ __ ] card so um i don't think i don't
know if that's the move especially to
your point that money is the motivator
here i don't think that gets it done um
we'll see we'll see if biz being or any
silver or some of these other guys bite
because i think he's supposed to fight
in august he announced so we'll see what
happens there
yeah uh but moving on to
uh outside of the youtube or stuff like
that
with the with the hamza gilbert fight
my question for you and there's nobody
better in the world to answer this and
i'm gonna use it probably as my own
opinion because i respect you so much
and i do say this to me you're the
smartest best journalist we have thank
you with with with hamzad
you know we've seen hype trains like
this conor mcgregor you know there's
some other guys that have come up paddy
pimlet is there i just did a food truck
with him in san diego which we can talk
about in a little bit but
with hamza
i've never been more excited
about a guy coming to the ufc i love the
the rise of a fighter the the rise that
and the in the the journey that conor
took us on it is the best there's
nothing like it in sports there's in the
nfl and then be there's nothing like
a a young talent with all this hype
coming in and then living up to it and
calling his shots and you know he has
this ego and this confidence and it's so
special and for hamza to go what i think
number 11
maybe he's going to fight neil magney no
one will fight him 11 to [ __ ] three
and they go all right here's gilbert
burns
and you know i'm i'm a guy i've been all
over his chipping standing in nuts dude
like you wouldn't believe you know i'm
all sold on him and then they give him
the gilbert fight and i was like god
just stylistically i'm like he's gonna
molly [ __ ] gilbert
and then you know it's a it's a fight
man you know some people fight of the
year but it's a [ __ ] fight i you know
you definitely the takeaway from it i
think because i had so much hope and
promise you know he did get hit a lot
didn't stick to a game plan um
you know he he fought more with his
heart than needed his head which is
alarming but it's also a guy going you
know from fighting jingling at whatever
he's ranked to [ __ ] number two
you know on on a pay-per-view and it's
your first you're not you didn't go to
number nine number eight which is a
tough task you went to [ __ ] number
two dude so my question for you is
is hamzat what we thought
or does he still have some
you know
a ways to go
is he ready for kermar usman kobe
covington
well so i've done a lot of thinking
about this one and when you say is he
who we thought the problem with the
framing of the question is what i found
out afterwards
was that everyone thought two different
things
some people thought he was
you know uh
the son of the god sent down to
dominate mere mortals and it would be a
matter of time merely before this all
happened and then some of those people
were like huh i guess he isn't that guy
okay yeah that was me that was me okay
which was a lot of people felt that way
in fairness a lot of him you were hardly
alone i was driving the train i was
driving the train okay fair enough on
the other side is people like me being
like okay he's obviously good i mean
that's a yeah yes yes but how good is he
i mean [ __ ] gilbert's you know
and i went down to south florida we sat
down with gilbert and i saw his training
man and i saw what kind of shape he was
in and how he was talking i was like i
don't know what's going to happen here
bro this is yep gilbert is not [ __ ]
around this time you know no
here's what i would say if you can beat
gilbert burns in your fifth ufc fight
and you fought like a jackass even
relative to what you're capable of yeah
you are pretty [ __ ] good i do think
he's ready for colby not sure if he's
ready for kamaru i guess we'll have to
see how he does against colby but dude
that was understand something that was
not hamza fighting that was hamzat
fighting less than what he's capable of
his coach being like what the [ __ ] are
you doing what the [ __ ] are you doing
follow the game plan he just punted on
the game plan and then went after
gilbert and dude he still won yes of
course if the point is
you can't beat robert whittaker fighting
like the way hamza did which is a
different weight class i understand but
the point but still a guy like robert
whitaker dude he doesn't make a lot of
mistakes he's not going to be baited
into [ __ ] he doesn't get caught with
the same things multiple times usually
right otasana can do it but he fights
very disciplined very strategic very
intelligent but very very aggressive as
well
hamzat did the opposite of that and
still won
and still won
so i would just point out like is he the
very best guy in the world at 170 pounds
i don't know i don't know but do i think
he's ready for colby if he fights in a
disciplined way yes i think he is very
much ready for colby
yeah and i say that and this is a guy on
the han i'm literally leading this train
to uh kajeka stand or
i'm driving the [ __ ] train from
chechnya to freaking calabasas dude i i
i said this after the fight
you know clearly didn't fight smart just
fought like a you know like leonard
garcia-ish just literally just a dog man
literally just a dog
but
he's lucky that it was gilbert burns and
that's not to i have gilbert on food
truck tomorrow he's lucky it was gilbert
burns and he eked his way out of that
thing because if he doesn't learn from
that that these i'll i'll even say in
the top six
if you fight like that nine times out of
ten you're gonna lose dude you you got
lucky man you got lucky that you were
able to pull this out of your ass
because
if that same hamzot shows up and throws
the game plan out the window there's not
a chance in hell he beats colby compton
there's not a chance in hell he beats
kamar hussman
or even for that there's not even a
chance they beat muhammad who could be
next if if they can't figure out with
kobe so at that tip of the spear those
top five or six guys you have to stick
to a game plan because you're you're not
going to beat those guys they're too
smart they've been in there too many
times they're too calculated so
i do think with with his you know the
camp he comes from his coach who's
phenomenal i do think they're gonna say
all right all right you did it man you
got out of your system we're never doing
that again because that's not gonna work
next time so i i do have hope that he's
learned and that he passed the test we
know he's [ __ ] good but if that if he
if for whatever reason i'm not saying
he's not but if he didn't learn and
thinks he can continue to do that and
sit on top of the cage while they're
walking lock on like it's [ __ ] friday
happy hour uh
you're not you're not gonna beat colby
dude you're kobe's going to molly whop
you man he has a game plan and you you
you you get you got to come up with the
game plan to beat a guy like colby so
i do think the hype is real
but there is an asterisk being it's real
if he learned from that
gilbert fight i think that's 100 the the
the truth and the other part
i would say is like yeah listen you can
say to him okay you got away with one
you got away with one you were able to
do this nonsense and you got away with
one but like why did he even attempt
that because i don't think he really
fully understood
that there are other people in the world
that are also hammers like him he didn't
realize that i don't think he fully
accepted that and then after the fight
what was the first thing he said what
was the first thing he said right after
the fight i'll never forget this when
phil barone fought evan tanner evan
tanner got his [ __ ] rocked the entire
fight but was able to come back and
after that listen the first one the
first thing evan tanner said when they
put a microphone in his face he was like
holy [ __ ] that guy hits hard the first
thing i believe i believe that hamzad
said was like that dude is [ __ ] tough
it didn't occur to him that somebody
could do what gilbert burns can do so to
your point now that he knows these dudes
in the top three they're not just gonna
fold like a lawn chair you gotta you
have to be disciplined otherwise they
will they will just simply take over you
i think you're right i think if he takes
this as a learning experience to then
drive forward he'll be fine always
remember different scenario different
kind of significance but when jon jones
was good enough to just watch youtube
and then beat guys in the ufc that was
fine but to take his game to the next
level he went to jackson's he had to do
something next level of course hamza
already had a good team but getting back
to what they're telling him to do
is only going to be good for him and i
think he should he he probably will
learn the lesson correctly
yeah i think you will do do you think
the ufc figures it out with kobe you
know me and chael were uh texting back
and forth because after the hamzat fight
literally you'll see on the the
calabasas fight command which i'm trying
to get you on dude but you're still good
you're not busy but i'm sorry bro it's
tough it's tough no i get it brother but
i'd love to have you on sometime we'll
figure it out but i text chael i said uh
this version of hamza does not beat
colby
and uh chill goes agree but i think
comes that's going to learn this you
know it's just the dog in them which you
want to see
but he said
i don't know if we get colby next
because he wants to get paid like moz
vidal
so he and you know they want to put him
on that that huge abc card which would
be amazing dude to be on abc and have
colby and hamzat and you know colby who
doesn't care about haters or any of that
negativity he's gonna even though it's
not russia he's gonna make it usa versus
russia and trump and that
i i'm all for it sign me up it's gonna
be chaos it's so much fun dude but
uh cheo was like hold your horses man
cause kobe ain't fighting anybody until
he gets paid what he's worth that's not
happening and you know and and i don't
and he goes and not he goes and i would
tell you i don't know what direction
it's going right now but i promise you
kobe's not going to fight unless he gets
what he's paid
man i hope he does but like what
leverage does he have okay they want to
make the fight i understand they want to
make it on abc even better
but dude how many times does the ufc
like bend over backwards for guys who
are
pay-per-view level stars but he would be
a low-level pay-per-view star um
i i just here's the thing we always come
back to this it's like dude what is the
leverage that connor's got some leverage
but even him not so much i go back to it
all the time in terms of how the ufc
makes their money it's so much
contractual pay it's not it's not
volatile in the way that it used to be
what is the way you're going to convince
them to do it and you can sit out you
can sit out but they just
dude they're arguably a monopoly like
what is one that does something i'm
gonna do is gonna do [ __ ] all so i hate
it for him but i i hope he gets paid the
guy you know colby can you can like him
you can hate him he's a good fighter who
deserves to get paid when he is owed but
i don't know if he's gonna get it this
way i mean i'd like i'd love to be wrong
if if you're kobe's management wouldn't
you just say
you guys paid
you know mazda all this much
you know like you you paid mozville yeah
he's beat him
so and also i i do think there's a world
where you know obviously kobe has the
charges uh against mazda all you know
being sucker punched at the restaurant
miami if i'm the ufc i go hey dude
kobe is a i'm sorry mozzarella is a big
star for us
if you carry on with these charges and
actual press charges felony charges
we lose out on a huge star
so if i'm kobe i'm like i'll drop the
charges
just agree to
the money here i'll fight harms out
whoever you want i'll drop the charges
and you're you're getting
what you're getting me you're getting
the hobbs out fighting on abc you're
getting mazda where the [ __ ] you want to
do with him play ball a little bit here
so i think colby has a little
negotiating power there i don't know his
exact numbers on paper in the draw i
think it really depends on
who they put colby against it can't i
don't think kobe's powerful enough just
on on his own to headline he has to have
an adversary there has to be a story
there it's very wwe he has to be the
heel so you know they're they're gonna
have to figure out that but i i do think
that he has a little bit of leverage
going i'll drop the charges no problem
pay me what i'm worth maybe yeah that's
an interesting angle as well that i
hadn't fully considered although the
other part is it could work the opposite
right it could go in a situation where
ufc says hey we want a bookie against
amazon on abc and he's like yeah eat
[ __ ] pay amy they're like no we're not
going to do that in which case he's like
right so i'm just going to go and
extract wealth from
what jorge masbadal has accumulated
through you know lengthy and difficult
court battles i mean i doubt he wants
that's the other part too is like does
he really want to spend a lot of time in
a courtroom [ __ ] with this you know
if there's a way out of it i would
imagine not because that's lawyers are
expensive too
also
weirdly jorge pleaded not guilty boy i
wonder what his defense is going to be
for that one that's going to be
interesting but neither here nor there
um
yeah maybe maybe because if he doesn't
i'll say this if he can't really
convince them to be like hey i'll play
ball if you play ball if that doesn't
work what would be the mechanism you
would point to that colby could get
himself paid
i i candidly don't know i really don't
know i you know i guess the move would
again but it's you're comparing apples
to oranges he'd go i beat the [ __ ] on
masvidal what are we doing here and
you're paying him all this money in the
ufc goes it's not even about winning or
losing it's about star power dude
so you know i
i don't know it's to me tough hopefully
this management's figuring it out man
you know yeah hopefully they're figuring
out because if they don't
you know
a guy who's coming off a huge win off
vicente luke the card was awful but that
main event was great vicente luke and
muhammad you got
muhammad who's like give me hamza dude
give me hamza i'm right there i'm you
know i've earned the shot give me give
me hamzat now can you do
muhammad vs hamzat and abc
just say it out loud let me know if the
public's going to buy it
i'll say it again you could do it i
don't know
little unfair i think you could do it
but you're asking
would that be what hamzap versus colby
would be no correct would not even be
close no no
not even close and abc we got to go all
out here daddy you know what i'm saying
yeah like dude there's i mean dana was
right like that's the perfect main event
for that occasion right that's the
perfect main event
but they got to get colby's compliance
and
you know him and dan have an always seen
eye to eye and he fought jorge with no
pay-per-view points i'd be better if i
was him to be quite honest with you i'd
be super bitter about it
i hope he gets paid dude i really do
me too brother uh uh i'm almost done
with you i know you got to do one of the
million shows that you do every day you
too [ __ ] you got like 50 000
podcasts it's crazy i know i'm exhausted
i can't i hate hearing myself talk
oh and then yeah and this pr tour i'm
going on by the end of it i'm just gonna
blow my head off but anyway that's cool
um
with uh i had patty pimlet on uh food
truck um
his manager hit me up with oh we're in
san diego
so i go man well we're shooting
calabasas and he's like just too far
patti's too busy with training and doing
everything he's doing can you guys get
to us
so i'm like let me talk to the team
literally a day notice
let me talk same with uh volkanovsky his
manager him but hey dude we're in la we
leave sunday
i'm on tour in phoenix dude
when do you want to shoot on sun easter
sunday these guys are savages
easter sunday my girl's like you're
doing what i was like i know let's let's
hide the eggs right i'll dress up as the
rabbit we'll hide the eggs and then i
get to go work and i'll be back but i
gotta go shoot this thing with
volkanovsky so we get it done on sunday
paddy pimlet's team uh i find a food
truck our the best food truck we've ever
had they came so highly recommend the
guys like yeah we're down
so we pulled off with paddy pimlet it's
one of my favorite interviews he's i
don't know if you've interviewed him
he's such a good person
he has that thing about him where
you know he just has it like i've never
had a guy i know you've had this where
you're interviewing someone you go oh
this kid gots it because he would do
he'd rip these promos and he wasn't he
most fighters you know
some have it but when they rip these
promos patty would look at the camera
not me he would do it to the fans into
the camera oh my god this kid is a very
[ __ ] savvy when it comes to media he
knows exactly what he's doing calls
himself the fifth beatle with his
haircut and you know i knew he was a big
deal
talking to his manager i didn't realize
how big of a deal he is
and i i asked patty about this and it's
kind of the
if there's gonna be a knock on paddy
um
you know you look at his first fights in
the ufc and obviously had a lot of hype
behind him coming to the ufc and what's
interesting about him again talking to
his manager hopefully i'm not online
sharing this
the ufc tried to sign him
two years before he signed the ufc
because he was making so much money in
cage warriors being the face of it and
fighting liverpool selling out these
huge arenas
that he's taking a pay cut coming to the
ufc so for two years you know sean
shelby and those guys are trying to get
them sign them and him his manager and
patty like i'm we're good man we don't
need to go over there and then finally
it's like all right let's let's let's
see what it's all about let's do it so
they came to agreement and
they were saying you hear it on food
truck that patty makes and it's not even
close and sugar shawn's the same way
paddy makes 20 times the amount of money
in a month not fighting than he does
fighting in the ufc
that's how big this kid has gotten doing
appearances and doing all the [ __ ] that
he's doing he's dealing with bar stool
but going back to you know the one knock
on patty
and i'd love to get your opinion on this
you know
there's hype trains like hamzat who's
literally molly whopping guys you look
at his copy strike numbers it's before
the gilbert fight you're like jesus the
guy doesn't get touched
with patty he's obviously not fighting
the level of competition hamzad is
and you know he's younger he's also a
different weight division you know
45 really he's a 55er he's a 55er and
when i interviewed him he's 210 pounds
you don't fight at 55. he's huge he's
bigger than me i call him the the
original liverpool thick boy he's bigger
than me dude he and he ate
[ __ ] four patties like literally
just went nuts
and then i go uh you know while we're
eating i go uh hey dude i i listen i
love uh food like you do man i struggle
with it like you do obviously you blow
the [ __ ] up between fights i go
but if they called you for like a short
notice fight like this huge opportunity
you're screwed
and he goes what i'm not even trying
doing the accent but imagine this an
accident he was what he was why would i
take a short notice fight
because i don't need that [ __ ] because
i'm not taking a [ __ ] that's never
worked out for anybody he goes again i
make more money not fighting
why would i put myself at a disadvantage
and he's again he's saying this to the
camera i'm like yo this kid's a [ __ ]
beast so back to my the question i have
for you when you look at patty do you
see
the same hope the same
promise as you're doing these other
contenders even though he's at 55 and
obviously he's not fighting
world beaters nor should he especially
at the level he's getting paid but
what i told him i said the thing that
makes me nervous is you've been hit in
every fight
and when when you start fighting you
know and you know it's better than
anybody luke when you when you start
fighting the the real
guys in the division you can't get hit
like that man
and his response was
i i always need to get hit to wake up to
feel like i'm in a fight i do it on
purpose and i also have and he goes and
i'm not making fun of my opponent he
goes i didn't respect those guys
i went in there to absolutely destroy
and put on a show once i start finding
bigger competition i'll start tightening
it up but right now i don't need to
i mean far be it for me to tell a pro
fighter what they should and shouldn't
do but to answer the question i would
say that that's probably a mistake i
think you need to
not that it will cost him necessarily in
the short run but that
um
fighting the way you intend to
in the future should be the way you
fight now and there should be a
consistency about that because that's
the way your process is going to get the
best when you need it so that's just my
personal opinion but again i'm sure that
they're you know they they know better
than me but that's the first thing i'd
say the second thing i'd say is yes he
is defensively vulnerable he gets hit an
unnerving amount and it rocks him an
unnerving amount of time so you're
asking me like where's my hype on him i
am decidedly neutral there are a lot of
people who think that he is some kind of
fraud and there's a lot of people who
think that he is the next thing of
mcgregor i don't think there's a lot of
evidence to conclude either of those
things the good part about what he has
is he has i would say a very good ground
game legitimately quite good i know he
is trying to make that even better he
trains with justin flores that's the jiu
jitsu coach of ronda rousey i'm sure you
know him he's great jflo you can catch
him on instagram he is phenomenal and
i've seen paddy's work with him it's
dude
daddy's good he's good he's very good
there but he has defensive
vulnerabilities in the stand up and the
kind that are a little bit
um
again they make you nervous but i do
think he can work on that taking these
fights the way he is is exactly the
right call for this stage i don't mind
it at all the only thing i would say is
i don't think it's just the defensive
vulnerabilities in the stand-up i saw
his fight i think it was one of his last
ones one of his later ones in cage
warriors want to say 2017 ish maybe
2018ish against a guy by the name of
soren bach sworn bach actually ended up
after that fight going to bellator i
think he fights on this baiter versus um
congo card in france
soren bach had
uh
patty took the fight to him
early on but then soren bach actually
out grappled him by the time they
reached the fifth round and it was
actually soren bach who won so to me
granted that was a while ago so i don't
know how i don't know how important that
is the only point i want to raise is
there's a lot of people who love him
because his personality is dynamic he's
got a really cool interesting way of
just sort of presenting himself to the
world and if he can monetize that buddy
take it as far as you can get every cent
you can not a bit of hate for me but i
think until he just does things against
better opposition the faith is i'm not
going to say misplaced because that's
the definition of faith but
um to me this confidence about like his
inevitability i would pump the brakes on
that but i'm not to declare that he is
going to be some bust either
let's see how the young kid does
and let's give him some time in a year
or two a lot of this could go away in
which case [ __ ] he's off to the races
yep now that that's a fair and uh smart
opinion for sure i think
you know one thing i do like is
you know mighty mouse said this dj said
this um he was referring to patty and i
think he might have mentioned sugar but
he i know he definitely said patty's
name
you know how patty turned down fights
and he you know he doesn't want to fight
the top 15 guys and dj goes dude when i
when i was fighting coming up you know
even when i was champ i'll fight whoever
i don't give a [ __ ]
and
don't get me wrong dj's one of the
greatest ever do it but
i like that these young kids
they're learning from the the older
heads going no no i know you did that
i'm not doing that dude how's that
worked out for you you know you know
granted he's one of the best and but are
you set and maybe dj is but in general a
lot of those guys take those short
notice fights or you know the donald
cerrone's uh some of these guys who have
fight whoever whenever and bow down to
the ufc and do all this stuff
it doesn't really work out if you look
at the history of the ufc so
i i like that sugar and that patty go no
no i'm good man i'm going at my pace
because our the mma fan base
we have this tendency it happens in
boxing too it's it happens even jake
paul with the youtubers where people
want to go i wanna see him verse canelo
alvarez i wanna see patty vs justin
gaichy i don't see sugar shawn versus
dominic cruz and they're going what why
would i do that i'm not getting paid to
fight those type of dudes
if you want to pay me to fight those
guys you want pay me equal compensation
let's do it but i don't need to be in a
this is a marathon not a sprint fellas
so i and i and i do see for the first
time that the ufc is actually
taking that into consideration you look
at suga who
i think for the first time has brought
up a young prospect the right way i
really do ozzy he had the cheeto uh
you know kind of
flubber you know for lack of a better
word there
he had the cheeto issue but it's it's
been a steady climb they didn't throw
them to the [ __ ] wolves like they did
with like a darren till which i think
dantel
can still come back and do some good
things and he has all the skill in the
world i'm i'm i'm rooting for him
but i think we've learned from that it
was too much too soon headlining in his
hometown and you know in liverpool and
he's fighting woodley you know and
he was clearly wasn't ready it was too
big of a moment so i think the ufc is
showing us that they've learned from
their mistakes and they are taking guys
like sugar shawn and uh patty and and
it's a marathon not a sprint which
you know as a former fighter i'd love to
see that man because boxing does that
that's one of the good things about
boxing boxing actually does that i agree
and i would tell you this like i
remember when i first got into coverage
when i was first around the sport you
would hear things like oh but i i fought
three guys in one night like i remember
for example i was arguing with someone
when uh hughes fought gracie or like ufc
60 or something
and i remember something like dude hoist
fought three guys in one night i'm like
yeah [ __ ] like plumbers and [ __ ]
like not everyone but you know
yeah he didn't fight three matt hughes's
in one night let me tell you and then of
course
beat the [ __ ] out of him like
demolished him and i'm like dude it's
just an old way of thinking about it i i
even used to hear things like oh i from
fighters oh i fought for free these guys
are getting paid now that's how long
i've been watching this [ __ ] you know i
remember stuff like that i thought when
it was illegal everywhere on the native
american casinos it's a different ball
game these days and remember what it's
called man it's called mma but at the
end of the day it is prize fighting
the fighting whatever you're going to do
for it the prize better be worth it if
you don't think it's worth it don't do
it so
these guys be like if you're going to
pay me x then i'm going to take a a
opponent that is commensurate with what
that financial reward will be and that
will just be what it is until you guys
decide to do more fine i don't i don't
have even the slightest issue with that
they're the ones risking their health
they're the ones risking their brains
they're the ones risking injury if they
decide that they want an easier opponent
because they're not getting paid enough
good i completely support them
yeah it just makes me happy that they're
learning from the from the older heads
and they're and you know there's the
amount of pressure that is on these
young prospects to
jump to the top you know and yeah i came
from that kind of cloth you know i'm
surrounded by shane carl and all these
guys and i beat two guys and i'm calling
out you know frank mayer and barnett and
these monsters i wish someone would have
came along like whoa whoa whoa whoa dude
do you want to be in this for five years
or 10 years because this is not the
10-year plan because let's say in some
weird world you do beat a gabriel
gonzaga who's ranked in the [ __ ] top
15 in the world
well what do you think snacks dude
there's no going back
you beat him
it's all you know then you're getting
the crow cops the nogueras the ben roth
you're off to the races dude and unless
you're ready for that and you can you
know dominate these guys and
reign at the helm for a long time it's
you're looking at a five-year career
bubba
but it's just not what i came up with it
was
fight fight the biggest name the highest
ranked guy and try and get to the title
shot and i just love that patty and
sugar going no no no hold on no no
that's not happening now the reason
they're doing that is because they're
making they're the two guys who are
making so much money outside of the
octagon
it's such a blessing that's the other
part too is they have the financial
runway to kind of play the game that way
a little bit good for them too i'm glad
about it some of these other guys are so
financially destitute as i'm sure you've
seen in gyms that they're just desperate
for any kind of opportunity to get some
air so to speak
and uh and uh they'll take on risk that
may be inadvisable for what you're
describing long-term viability but in
the case of sugar shawn and patty pimlet
barstool or twitch or whatever is giving
them all that money dude it gives them
options and options gifts for and
they they are able to make much more
informed sober decisions by virtue of
these other streams of income it just
shows you what what kind of how smart
they are for doing that and for all the
opportunities they've you know um
created for themselves and i support it
to your point you know the usc is a
little bit all over the place with it
though like on the one hand they'll slow
roll this and then i say oh hamzad yeah
neil magney has got a neon sign being
like i'll take the fight and they just
bypass him and give him gilbert graham
they thought he was ready for it and
that was a bit of a wake-up call but in
general you're right that you're we are
seeing more of these pimplet o'malley
types
who are who are slow rolling it on
purpose for a few different reasons
which i think long term will only serve
to serve to benefit them
agree brother well i'ma let you go man i
know you're busy and time is is money
for you these days man you're crushing
it trying bro you're one of my favorite
people to talk to man i i i say this
from any
uh microphone that i get in front of i
think you're the best we have in the
business man and uh you're my favorite
people so i appreciate you taking the
time bro well i appreciate you having me
here on this new adventure of yours same
show but new venture and uh i don't know
when i'll make it out to california but
i promise i will do my absolute best to
find a free weekend and and we'll have a
lot of fun
you texting man will make it happen
appreciate it take care of that little
one uh luke thomas everybody
there you have it
the very smart the very knowledgeable
the very
busy
uh
luke thomas also the very skinny the
very skinny i'm not the only one getting
shape around here he looks fantastic
he was the thickest boy he was built
like a polar bear yeah and now he is a
lean mean
uh podcasting machine man luke thomas
looks fantastic so hopefully you guys
enjoyed that uh one him and chill man my
my absolute two favorite people to talk
to
i'm rogan's up there
but those guys man if there's just
um
a chemistry when i talk to them that
it's just always there and you know and
when it comes to
i think the best part of my job is
you know luke thomas is obviously huge
in the space joe sonin's obviously huge
in the space joe rogan's the biggest in
the space
they're all much more knowledgeable much
more
um
you know i just they should have such a
different opinion usually than i do you
know i'm more of a hype boy about a high
beast fuckboy about it and you know i
don't do the research like they do so i
love bringing those different views into
the show and clearly my fan base is
familiar with luke thomas and if you're
not you are now he is fantastic so let's
get some current events chin and then
get moving dude what do you got well
first can we cheers to your special oh
thank you sir yeah for sure cheers and
to the fans and to the fan yeah
yeah yeah it's been a grind man it is a
beast when you drop a special
and uh for those la locals you'll see
the billboard up off hollywood boulevard
i'm talking in the heart of hollywood
boulevard i'm sure one of the guys from
team is going to get a dope pick of that
i'll blast it on social media but you'll
see it if you're local and you drive by
it send a pic man i'll blast that bad
[ __ ] out and then you also see
uh the billboards i think it's off
sunset and melrose
uh the laugh factory um is gonna put me
on their billboards as well so that's
awesome yeah so it should be cool man
we'll see i i don't know if billboards
do anything these days it's more of a
flex
it's more it's like i notice him
yeah i noticed him but i don't know if
you notice and go oh there's a special
you know you go to it you know it's more
of a flex
we'll see that's all it is
like you know
it's like having you know if i put my
face on a bus stop you know they're all
over
is anybody like oh man i need to call
frank azar
my back hurts when i slipped at tony
roma's too you know i don't know if
there's a lot of personal injury ones
yeah yeah we'll see it's all personal
yeah is that mexican with this mustache
yeah everywhere but see we notice it
it's like a couldn't tell you his name
or the number how to get a hold of them
but
it works yeah it works
yeah again i don't know if billboards
work you know we'll see
we'll see we'll see what yeah and i
don't know if we can
again if if you're basically just off
views if you know man that came from the
billboard you know i don't know how
we're going to prove that analytics will
be tough
yeah so for me you know the billboard
and i also took out a uh a lot of
marketing in the newspaper just kidding
what if i didn't uh newspaper magazine
the whole marketing came from newspapers
and magazines oh yeah hilarious and vhs
tapes we also wearing a lot of vhs tapes
blockbusters i'm all over the
blockbusters is there just one brendan
yes there is
so yeah one last one we'll see man all
right what do you got jim uh so there
were some fights over the weekend you
talked to um luke about
i'm sure a lot of these but so cyborg
once again won
that was a fun fight though you know
that arlene uh blanco
dude tank yeah she you know granted she
took some heavy shots i think she got
molly whopped in the second the only
reason it wasn't 50 45
is chris cyborg need uh her when she was
down illegally so they took a point from
chris on that pretty dominated fight um
but all
all the
all the respect to arlene man she is a
tough cookie she is a little tank and
you're a
former professional uh world champion
boxer too and man cyborg her kicks was
the difference the takedown's clearly
the difference it was a fun fight to
watch
you didn't think you'd go past the
second but definitely did and then stats
versus juan archuleta who i love juan
archuletta uh stotz the the the knee
that he landed was vicious incredible
yeah good card though man fun to watch i
watch the entire thing
cool man uh yancey also won
which is great
uh your boy i know that's it that's kind
of crazy too i didn't expect that but
yeah that happened
also the biggest fight over the weekend
was tyson fury dillian white correct uh
watch this one um
didn't watch the undercard um just had
time to with the kids and they're at the
pool came in for the main event fury uh
white and i'm i'm close with france's
agent and he didn't share this with me
so we're not that close i go man uh best
case scenario
um fury gets a crazy knockout and rips a
promo about francis which is exactly
what he responded fingers crossed
hey dude you could have been yeah we're
kate we're ringside and if he wins he is
gonna do it because he goes fingers
crossed maybe it's fingers crossed that
tyson ferry gets the knockout you know
and this happens and also maybe he if
tyson some weird world he lost he didn't
want it maybe me to be like oh francis
is there you know although i'm not a
journalist i'm not trying to break news
you know i i'm not going to get on but
hey if france you know if tyson wins
francis is ringside he's going to get in
you know i'm i'm not that guy you know
what markell you don't need to
you could have told me dude you know so
uh but it was cool to see that this is
happening that's only happened for a
while because francis in the knee
surgery but
it's just again
you know these crossover fights stuff
like that
it's not that the sport needs it or it
moves
the sport in a direction that
purists want to go
you should view it as
francis won the lottery
francis if the fight with him in fury
comes to fruition and it actually
happens
he never has to fight again he's set for
life his kids kids kids are set if he
invests his money right and he's not a
dumbass with it he never has to get
punched in the face again
and that
is what you should want for your
favorite fighters and francis
has been able to achieve that now it
hasn't happened but it looks like it's
going to happen if that were to happen
you as a as a fight fan
you should be happy that francis was
able to get this done it's insane dude
and shout out to markel and his entire
team who believed in this when nobody
else did and they and they and they
fought against the ufc and you know
markel and francis both of them i'm not
just going to say one but both of them
went through you know the it's their
andy dufresne from shawshank redemption
they crawled through some [ __ ] dude and
the amount of hate and negativity that
came their way
but man was it the right choice because
now now you have all
you have all the chips in your in your
corner now man yeah you're fighting
and i you i know luke thomas said canelo
i'd argue it's tyson still
you're fighting the biggest name in
boxing
it's great
thank god it looks like it's it looks
like it's happening yep and also i saw
francis with the pictures at the ufc pi
so i kind of feel like they're still in
good terms so they're probably going to
work something out i hope they do man
yeah that'd be amazing but yeah that was
awesome and then do you see tyson goes
what's that yeah i think i forget what
he called me he was basically like let
me see what that [ __ ] looks like yeah
decent not great i wouldn't say i'm an
expert at it you know
i'm not jordan peterson or luke thomas
i'm all right at it i definitely have my
blunders but um
when he said
his penis called it would accord
whatever
oh he wants to know how big his dick is
great question great question
because that is a massive man so you'd
hope that it's it's a panther tale
you know
i'm pretty sure he's a good guy
but i like how they were cool about it
too yeah i think tyson was way more
friendly but they're both they're both
down to do this yeah it's awesome yeah
yeah and also tyson's doing francis a
favor he doesn't need for sure
sunset and be set yeah you know much
money tyson he's sad dude yeah he's
retired he said he's absolutely yeah
he's upset he's doing francis a huge
favor yeah i love it
but this is also you see this is also
why i think tyson fury's the best ever
do it
for multiple reasons i mean we can get
into the technicalities of it as far as
his fighting style his size his footwork
is
defense how he can go offensive and
defensive
we can get all that his resume
this argument joshua's resume is a
little better but
you know joshua's lost recently you know
to uh the the music uh
uh no um
the mexican oh andrews yes so losing to
ruiz get you know there so there's not
too much of an argument there so um
you look at what tyson fury came back
from with his mental health and still
you know at the peak of his game and his
the trilogy fights with deontay wilder
and
you know the klitsch go fight when he
beat klitschko it was a different time
than when uh
anthony joshua beat klitschko so i i
would say that tyson fury even though it
was in the most exciting i think joshua
klitschko is my favorite fight of all
time it's most entertaining fight i've
ever seen i was on the edge of my seat
but fury did it when klitschko was also
not in a decline as far as career-wise
so
again that's another point for fury
um
but just with the mental health stuff
and you know getting so big and battling
that and coming back
um
and his personality and how he's so
positive
he he's my favorite yeah he's my
favorite incredible i [ __ ] love him
yeah he's my favorite
i love hearing him talk about whatever
on his instagram i just love he all of a
sudden you know he don't have to fight
he has a career in entertainment
podcasting i know he wants to do wwe
which you'd be phenomenal at yeah for
sure this guy's the limit for him and
he's just getting started which is so
cool
so here are the opening odds
and it's pretty crazy man sometimes it
makes sense it does but yeah it's pretty
crazy minus 1500 for tyson fury plus
boxing anything 750 yeah the only way
that those numbers would get a little
more even
even if you know so if they go mma
gloves those numbers still going to be
the same maybe maybe a minus 1300
because you know francis in mma gloves
and he does hit hard but you know it's
i don't know probably harder than
francis diante wilder
and he you know that first fight yeah he
did land it but outside that he never
landed again so
a guy like tyson fury is very aware of
what francis brings to the table so the
only way those odds come down if they do
as luke thomas alluded to
they do some sort of dirty boxing where
they don't break it up when they're in
the clinch so francis can do that but
also that's not really france's thing
either
so he's just he goes crazy on striking
yeah yeah so he he should be a big
underdog but still yeah great fight
yeah i'm super excited if that happens
hopefully it happens
uh so mike tyson i guess he's had back
and forths with the paul brothers and
so jake does want to he mentioned he
wanted to fight him and mike's actually
saying he's actually down to fight him
and it could be like a big payday like
62 million huge payday for both of them
huge payday but do you think
jake look i mean he looks awesome right
now but mike tyson
at 50 something 55 i mean we but you
know i don't think you can base this off
of mike versus roy jones to me that was
like a glorified exhibition sparring
match where nobody was really serious
taking anybody out so i i don't know
exactly where tyson's at right now
but i did see him beat this [ __ ] up guy
on a plane he looked pretty good that
was funny that guy deserved it right his
face was so funny too yeah he's like
yeah yeah okay
nobody likes that guy no everyone's like
yeah that makes sense so he looked
pretty freaking
agile that that jet blue yeah you know
so
take my money
take honey
uh this is pretty crazy so dan hardy
actually is returning to combat sports
he's gonna box diego sanchez in
another exhibition fight they're boxing
boxing not i see i'd rather see it mma
yeah i don't see mma i wish they would
do mma
but i mean like this is the the hot
thing right now the whole boxing
exhibition stuff so
yeah uh i'm into it
you know i love dan hardy yeah he's so
he's he's such a great com
sanchez hall of famer so
i'm into it again if it was up to me
there'd be mma
but i'm into it all right yeah
cool uh this one sucks robert whitaker
is now not fighting marvin vittori
apparently has an injury damn i love
whitaker yeah so he said he'd be back in
a few months but
yeah he can't and then i saw the tories
calling out
uh if he i'm pretty he called up hamzat
right she's called out a bunch so he
goes we're back at this i think i'm the
only 85er that can say that has never
pulled out of a fight but anyway smash
boyz i'll get you back to back let's do
it i wanted to die just show up
and then he tagged hamza and darren till
and the matchmakers and the management
and dana white yeah
uh yeah again take my money if it's
there until i think this would be great
for darren till to get back on the horse
i do like darren till's chances in that
fight um
homs obvioutory they can't take my money
i know that's freaking awesome fight
even though it's at 85 you know hamza
could can be at 85. so
we'll see
but yeah i'd love it i think i think
paulo costa also answered to this too
like he's down to fight him but then
that was a shitty fight
yeah i'm not great and victoria's like
dude get out of here yeah he wasn't even
entertaining it give me like two more
chances almost
[Music]
noon all right so remember shoe face
from the ufc antonio college yeah when
the ultimate fighter uh yeah i think he
was a tough you know tough winner um so
he was saying
recently that he made more money in one
year at the pfl
versus his entire career at the seven
year career at ufc it's because he's a
champion but the other thing
with that i know the headlines like well
yeah he made more money yeah it looks
crazy but he's also a champion and then
also
he won a million bucks and then the
other caveat here is he was on the
ultimate fighter contract which is the
worst we said that was without the
question yeah but take it from your boy
here man i was fighting
literally legends on the ultimate
fighter contract for how much six fights
so i started off at i think eight and
eight
you know wow going eight and eight
ten and ten twelve and twelve fourteen
fourteen
when you finally you know you're
fighting gonzaga fourteen and fourteen
you're fighting cro cop for 16 16.
you know you're fighting no guerra you
know for 16 and 16. like
that that'll be a fighter contract at
the time
that show was so big and season 10 is
the biggest they've ever had i like to
think it was killing me but i think it's
because kimbo slice
and uh shout out to kim's slice rest in
peace yeah definitely had nothing to do
with me but um
at the time even though it's similar to
like a sugar shawn or patty at the time
even though you're getting paid less
from the ufc to fight these monsters
which was
complete [ __ ]
i because i had so much notoriety coming
off the season because i did well on
there i was making so much endorsements
yeah so it's giver it's
it's weird but if i was a if if i was
currently like
a manager or agent of uh a ufc fighter i
would not do the uh the ultimate fighter
nobody's watching it's behind you know
espn plus a pay wall
um if it's your only way to get in the
fc i guess but dana white contender
series much more
notoriety
much more exciting
the contracts are way friendlier so i
would
advise most fighters if you're gonna do
it to go that direction or
do what patty did where you build
yourself up get experience in a cage
warriors or you know uh some some other
way and then get in there
you know the more traditional way yeah
ultimate fire these days is not the way
to get in the ufc yeah nobody's watching
yeah you i didn't know and the
contractor you know it's a [ __ ]
i think he said like 10 years or
something
yeah mine was yeah
yeah nuts
nuts well there you go
uh so
the odds are the opening odds are
available now for john jones versus
stipe and jon jones is a
i mean that's pretty big right minus the
headline says sizable favorite that's
not that sizeable especially at
heavyweight and you know remember
vegas
wants to get your money they want you to
be like whoa i think stephen can do it
they're they're they're they're edging
you dude it's [ __ ]
you know they want you to bet they want
more money on the fight so
you know that's opening odds for a
reason you got to realize that these
these vegas bettors uh who create the
odds these experts
they're doing it for they want you to be
think stipe has a better chance to win
so you put money on them that's all
these odds when they come out with this
unless it's just something crazy like
francis fury
you know which is such a big difference
but stipe jones as luke thomas alluded
to
the same time i said eluded alluded to
the word of the day but what luke thomas
alluded to is
there's so many
unknowns about both stipe and jon jones
he goes i have no idea what to expect
which i think is what makes the fight
great which is also why draftkings
didn't see so much money bet on both
guys because one person might believe
this the other believes this so these
odds are to get you to bet yeah
yeah that makes sense
is that it chin that could be it that
works right man yep uh we got a late
start today and we have luke thomas on
so
um that's it man hope you guys enjoyed
luke thomas uh thank you for liking
subscribing uh watching everything i do
again uh it's a big week for your boy
my 30 minute special
is dropping this mother trucking tues or
thursday morning
thursday morning on thick boy youtube
the gringo poppy if you're gonna post
about it uh the hashtag is the gringo
poppy hashtag the gringo poppy
and uh again we're doing a giveaway
we're doing a fun little thing uh on
thursday when it drops anybody post you
watching it the most creative unique
funny whatever post uh has a chance to
win a 5x7 poster of the gringo poppy
autographed by your boy here and then
also
five of you will get that and a signed
bottle of the best whiskey you ever
taste in your life tiger thick we're
sending out five bottles of that
five signed by uh five by seven cards
signed by your boy and then uh hundreds
of others will also win the 5x7 poster
of the gringo poppy the only way you can
enter use the hashtag the gringo poppy
post a picture of yourself your family
your dog the animals your aunt uncles
stepmoms your gay brother your cousins i
don't care who it is watching the gringo
poppy and we'll blast that out to you
guys and those will be in the mail by
next week so thank you guys so much
again the merch drops tuesday tomorrow
at 9 00 a.m
the gringo poppy shirt show your love
show your support your boy designed the
shirt for the special
they go on sale tomorrow at 9 00 am and
also with the gringo poppy shirt we're
also releasing thick boy fight club
which is a
throwback to the abbott kenny fight club
this is thick boy fight club hoodies
tees and then also thick boy trucker hat
snapbacks you'll see me rock on rogan
again designed by your boy
because all i do is rock other people's
hats and they're like hey how about you
rock your own [ __ ] uh that makes sense
so we have the thick boy trucker hats
dropping as well and those are only
available for a week literally seven
days
to get that trucker hat and then it
comes you can only get it in person if
you see me at one of my shows on tour so
it will be available on tour on tour the
merch can only get if you come to a show
so we have special merch that's just for
the fans that come see me do stand up
this is completely different merch than
you see online that's by design
so uh the trucker hats will be available
that have a kenny sorry the thick boy
fight club uh tees in gray black the
cream hoodie which my favorite hoodie of
all time and the black hoodie and then
the the gringo poppy
special shirts drop tomorrow that's
tuesday at 9 00 a.m april 26 on
thickboy.com
outside that you will seem you're gonna
be so sick of me talking because for the
next week i'm on all your favorite
podcasts promote my special so
the work begins um
but uh next thursday friday saturday i
am in charlotte north carolina at the
comedy zone charlotte come get some one
of my favorite clubs the comedy zone is
charlotte north carolina mugsy boggs is
opening up for me and rex chapman is
featuring so if you're a fan of them
come on out just kidding they will not
be there but the thick boy squad will be
there and then uh after charlotte i'm in
philadelphia pennsylvania may 19th
through the 21st and then in june we
kick the summer off in portland oregon
june 9th through the 11th
uh in july i'm in san diego at the laugh
factory san diego where i shot the paddy
pimlet food truck and that's it man but
charlotte you're up next
i don't care about any of that the big
thing is thursday on thick boy youtube
thursday morning the gringo poppy 30
minutes of fury of light my latin family
up come get some i worked hard on it if
you pass the billboard off hollywood
boulevard snap a pic i'll blast it out i
love you guys hopefully i made you proud
thank you so much for watching
subscribing liking everything i do
buying to take you to any show that i do
i wouldn't have a career without you
guys
so uh yeah this is for you cheers
and the album drops oh my god chin
there's so much [ __ ] going i forgot
we should uh outro this with the song
that you
jelly roll and little brows did
cool with me the thick boy album also
drops on thursday
the thick boy album that little brows
has created and i've had some part of
will feature
one of my favorite people on the planet
mike stud
chin
uh jelly roll uh we'll post the graphics
so you guys can see it um
eric griffin crystalia bert kreischer
has a song he goes so hard to paint
um
yeah man it's uh
i
i can't thank little brows enough this
all came from we'll rap on this but this
all came from
one of the things that give me uh joy
and satisfaction is the same thing that
got me to where i'm at probably what you
guys know of me is i've had so many
people help me when they didn't need to
they put out a hand or put me on the
show
some kid with ct that's coming off a ufc
career that's trying to get into comedy
and stand up and so many people have
helped me get to the point where i'm at
now
so now that i'm here and i have a chance
to give back it's my favorite thing to
do on this [ __ ] planet despite
whatever you hear it is literally my
favorite thing to do
so
little brows is a guy who won
a rap contest on a show i called a show
called king of the sting with theovan at
the time it's just me and theo and we
had an all-white rap contest uh which
started off as a joke we had all these
submissions from these white rappers
that some were so terrible but that was
part of the show they were in on the bit
and then we got a a freestyle from a
gentleman named austin
now when austin submitted his video
austin had these set of eyebrows that he
was born with and i said check out the
the brows on this one like you know the
show we make fun of people we roast
people so i'm making fun of his eyebrows
but in a good way
and uh you know the kids now everyone's
a little oozy little vert little this
little baby little wayne all this little
[ __ ] so that's little brows
well little brows is a gentleman who was
a former addict and has worked on
himself and now he gives back and he
works at um an addiction place
counseling canceling and he's a single
father and has a daughter and he's such
a good person
but outside that he is
so [ __ ] talented for me to have this
get on thick boy and collab with him
and give him a platform so you guys can
hear what a talented human being that he
is
and the last album that he did the king
and the sting
podcast album which was mainly thick boy
um he just got a plaque from spotify
because went over a million
streams
so my goal in all this is a
i get docs whenever i use sample music
on youtube or twitter instagram doesn't
care but in general i do so much
promo and marketing if i use a drake
song
on instagram it's fine but youtube i'll
get docs i can't use it so i said how
can we figure this out and then i
thought of
austin aka little brows
i said hey is there a world where you
come up with music that i can use on
tour and walk out to and use for a promo
yeah that's easy man i write songs in my
sleep
so let's do it
well he's been doing it and if you
listen you'll see on the gringo poppy
special the intro and the outro where
they show all the pictures of how the
the set came together it's all little
brows man it's all little brows so
my only goal in
any of this
is
soon
that little brows is too busy to
deal with my [ __ ] on think boy any
of that and he's
mainstream and he's recognized for
this insane talent that he has and
you'll hear how talented chin is on
there and the other thing about this
album is
some of my favorite people on this earth
are music artists like jelly roll he's
such a unique loving guy and mike stud
who me and him have been friends since i
was fighting the ufc because
i was running the santa monica stairs at
10 o'clock at night before i fought
travis brown and i used his song as
motivation and i posted it and he
reached out and he wasn't that big at
the time he's huge now huge but he
reached out and was yo man appreciate
you blasting out the song and we just
started connecting he was a former
athlete now he's doing rap and
we've just been boys ever since
and he's one of my favorite people on
this planet and you'll see me rocking
his merch and i support him and go to
his show so
stud made it but the point is is
being involved with little brows and
just having a little a glimpse behind
the the
the door on how the sausage is made in
music and how talented chin and little
brows and jelly roll mike stud and
they're some of my favorite people and
that they're adding the thick boy and
can use their music on promos and you
know
it it it's a really special thing so
again my whole goal in this is
not financially i make no money off this
i you know i fund it but i make no money
i don't i don't care about the money on
this
my only goal
is for a single dad in little brows for
you guys to see how [ __ ] talented he
is and his music gets played on the
radio and i'm gonna do everything in my
power which you know i'm not kevin hart
or joe rogan or you know some of these
other guys but hopefully i can make some
sort of impact in his life where you
guys realize how talented he is and he
quits you know working whatever job he's
working uh he provides for his his
daughter and uh that's the only goal
here and i think you guys would dig it
and it is so good
it is so good so after that long rant of
sucking little brows off and chin and
jelly roll and i said this so many times
even off camera how like you wanted to
make sure little bells makes it yep and
quit his job so it's real it's authentic
it's real yeah see you're also just as
talented and i don't want you to quit
because then thick boy would be super
[ __ ]
so if you're like hey man i can't come
in monday i'm touring you know i'm
opening up for [ __ ] post malone or
some [ __ ] i'm like what so that would be
heartbreaking but i also understand and
be proud of
you um
but there's only one way to end this
very special episode of the shob show
and that is with music from little brows
chin and jelly roll the complete album
which is so freaking good drops thursday
on spotify apple itunes amazon music
wherever you listen to music it drops
listen to it blast it out it's literally
if you've been on tour
and came to my shows it's the music i
walk out to it's the music they play
before the show starts it's all little
brows he's the genius behind it
unfortunately i am not because i cannot
rap or sing or create music
so without further ado
i love you guys watch the gringo poppy
this thursday on think boy youtube but
enjoy
the smooth sounds of chin
jelly roll
and little brows
see you on the other side
[Music]
i'm built for this been working my whole
life for this
no taking breaks i get up and i crying
for this no i don't ever complain i
don't got the time for that if things
don't go my way i just get up and go
change it i'm talking about 10 000 hours
of blood sweat and tears and they all
wanna talk but they're not even here
when i need them the most and they all
disappear i was living in fear but i
switched up the gear
i don't see the ten thousand dollars i
put in
they don't see the pain
[Music]
i can't imagine quitting cause this is
[Applause]
[Music]
the bottom been grinding and getting
mine still the same oh gee i'm feeling
like genuine before the fame singing or
spitting rhymes facing my fears in the
gutter with pennywise you don't know
about my struggle the nights that i
hustled and slept in the van got off the
road from 200 shows and still came home
with less than a grand selling my
mixtapes at the same corner store that i
used to flip way i prayed for my big
break but nobody came through to get my
[ __ ] straight pushing forward every day
and i just play my part the trailer that
i used to rent now i can buy that
trailer
[Music]
i can't imagine quitting cause this is
[Music]
can't imagine quitting that's just not
in my blood
[Music]
so one more thing brennan yeah
the team and i have been working on some
stuff for the last few weeks yeah
to surprise you with
so i'll just play it for you no way
brendan i think right now is the time
that i tell you how proud i am of you
but the real word is impressed looking
back of when you and i were in the gym
together and trying to train to go on
and be cage fighters to where you are
now with your second comedy special
coming out man i gotta tell you this is
awesome congratulations
what's up buddy
um
congratulations
gringo poppy it's pretty cool your
second special you took your time on
this one
um
you know i um
that there's a i was scrolling through
instagram and uh
there's this guy working out there this
is you know he's doing something
and uh the voiceover says
people aren't proud of you they're just
surprised you keep making [ __ ] happen
you ever think about that
and i thought to myself
no i'm
not surprised you keep making [ __ ]
happen i'm just proud of you
that's a big difference i'm proud of you
because i know
i mean this has been a [ __ ]
and i think in the uh darkest two years
that we've we i mean for us anyway that
we've met since we've met
uh you kept kicking the sandbag down the
road
and uh here we are
you did this special
it's very exciting i remember when you
texted me and you said i'm just really
excited because i captured on
camera what i've been working for
and
yeah i'm not surprised
i'm not surprised
you're the toughest guy i know and i
love watching you take a leadership role
i love watching what you've built and
what you continue to build i love
i love the fact that you are becoming um
somebody who's
becoming more compassionate more loving
more understanding
as you get older and as you get more
successful i think it's pretty awesome
i think it's the definition of a leader
i think you're embracing your best side
your best self and
and i love you i love you for
being there for me in you know probably
the darkest not probably but definitely
the darkest
time of my life
but you were always there man
and i think you've been a leader in this
[ __ ] whole thing because you were
just like [ __ ] all these people and
circle the wagons
so
what can i say my friend
i'm not surprised i'm just proud
i'm excited as well
all right
what's up mr thick boy himself i want to
congratulate you on your second special
gringo poppy i'm excited to see it man
good luck and congratulations
brendan schaub it's your boyfriend jeff
dye
very proud of you buddy two specials
i've got zero you already have two that
just shows that you're a better worker
and you're funnier and you're better and
stronger and you can beat people up and
more hands well actually i'll take
handsome i'll take handsome but anyways
i'm proud of you i love your brother uh
go crush it it's gonna be awesome i'm
excited to watch it hopefully watch it
with you good work
what's up big b damn i got dandruff
dang boy that [ __ ] is big too huh
looks like my dandruff has been doing
coke boy um
what's up player i'm at my grandmother's
house right now but uh
just chilling man about to grill up some
oysters actually
um
just wanted to say what's up oh wanted
to say this man congratulations on the
special baby way to get it done baby
gang
gang
love
love
what's up sting
i'm proud of you it's your second
special and it's going to do great
things for you i know a lot of people
will see it you've been working really
hard you should be really proud of
yourself i'm gonna keep this short
because i know a lot of guys are saying
congratulations but congratulations and
also congratulations the podcast it's uh
it's everywhere you get
everywhere you get podcasts
proud of you bro
yo b what's up man uh paul verzi here
and i just wanted to congratulate you
brother on your second special the
gringo poppy uh
wish you all the best with it getting
one is one thing but doing two is
another so congratulations again man all
the best and i see you
bishop congratulations on your second
special here's to 17 18 19 and 20 more
tell the haters to suck your big brown
baby
dick congratulations to my man keep
kicking ass
always bet on shop hasn't failed me yet
what's up b congratulations on getting
your second special man it's john atk
just here in the home office in south
florida but wanted to take a minute to
congratulate you
not surprised [ __ ] not
surprised always bet on shop
congratulations man i look forward to
seeing you out west soon but uh big
things man special number two let's go
what's up brendan it's your boy
chappelle lacy here you know who i am
back with lacy i just want to
congratulate you on your special doing
it all yourself putting it all together
yourself your own network it's an
amazing thing and i'm proud of you
brandon just want to say congratulations
on your second special gringo papi uh
good for you great name and um listen
dude you know me i'm keto now and like i
say every time i see you when i see you
baby i'm gonna nibble on those
cauliflower ears cause you got two
specials and you got some money
hey what up chef i just want to say
congrats on your special man i'm glad
you're finally embracing your mexican
roots it is chingong way
take care brother
what's up brandon it's giannis i wanted
to congratulate you on your second
stand-up comedy special on an amazing
feat that is
a stand-up comedy special for every year
you've been doing comedy
you're ahead of your time my friend you
got out of
mma
and got into a real blood sport
comedy um
you know
managed to avoid controversy congrats on
that as well
um that's big you know we got to do a
lot of fighting nowadays
and um
the future comedy i think you're it
because now we're getting hit on stage
so
i think pretty soon it's just it's only
going to be guys like you out there who
uh can hit back with force you know
it's um
it must be nice to be comfortable up
there and know that hey if anyone comes
and tries to [ __ ] smack me
you know
i know how to kill them or you know i
don't know where your jujitsu is at but
you're a big dude so
you can knock them out i know it's gonna
be funny i can't wait to see it man
congrats congrats on number two
big boy
big boy
what's up brandon my friend
um
damn i don't even know what to say but
ever since i made fun of you at the
improv because i was like what is this
ufc fighter doing thinking he could do
comedy
and since that moment
you've proven to be a person that
attacks everything that you do with the
same sort of energy to be successful
you got a an energy that
that's why your fans love you that's why
people want to be around you that's why
people like working with you that's why
people work hard for you it's because of
you it's because of what you have in
your heart and your soul i truly
appreciate that i admire the work that
you've done and look at you now two
specials in releasing another one right
now it's uh it's great man
it's great i'm proud of you i'm older
than you so i could be proud and proud
of you and i appreciate you bringing me
into your fold
uh with the king and the sting crew and
everybody and
um you know it's a testament to you as a
person and congratulations
and i can't wait to see what happens
next
what up boy
just want to say congrats on the special
really proud of you getting it out there
it's going to be really good um
nothing's been more fun than uh touring
this with you for the past year or so
and yeah let's just keep it going
hey boo
me and the boys um we just wanted to let
you know that we are super proud of you
um especially me i am so proud of
everything that you have accomplished
everything you've done
all the years that we've been together
the family that we have built um i'm
just
i'm really proud of you and the boys are
too um tiger do you want to say
something to your daddy
i hope you have a good show
love you
he hopes you have a good show bossy do
you want to say something to your papa
say good luck he wrote i love you daddy
oh daddy
we love you boo and we are so proud of
you congratulations on your special we
can't wait to see it
hey brynn just wanted to congratulate
you on your upcoming special that you
self-produced and self-published that is
fantastic you're doing so great you
surrounded yourself with some really
good people who really have been able to
help you to be successful at doing this
i know i'm very excited to see it and i
know that deborah wants to see it as
well i'm sure all your fans do you're
doing really really great and i
absolutely love
uh all that you've accomplished i'm sure
this will be the first one of many more
love you buddy bye
you son of a [ __ ]
dude
i can't believe you guys put that
together
oh thanks man
ugh that means the world to me thank you
you